[Music]
this is just what argentina said it
needed
millions more doses of the vaccine to
fight covet 19.
this in the week the country passed the
grim total of 100 000
deaths from the pandemic
our government and our president have
decided working with various
laboratories
that we will get the vaccines we need to
effectively put an
end to this nightmare pandemic
more than 30 percent of argentina's 45
million inhabitants
have received their first jab then
supplies started to dry up
the majority of those arriving in latin
america coming from russia
and china an imbalance washington was
keen to change
now also donating vaccines to brazil
colombia peru and ecuador
these vaccines are recognized for their
efficiency and security they will save
millions of lives
they're destined to be given to
youngsters aged between 12 and 17
as soon as that's been approved by the
u.s drug agency
argentina has bought another 20 million
doses of moderna
for delivery early next year this
donation will help to stifle accusations
from the global south
that wealthy nations were hoarding too
many of the vaccines for themselves
and that the biden administration
recognises that tackling the pandemic
truly is a global issue
argentina has negotiated several more
deliveries from russia china and the uk
and it will soon start manufacturing its
own vaccines
under license from drug companies in
those countries
i'm better protected so i can have a
normal life
i had covered two months back i'm okay
now but here i am
better protected
it's a strange experience being
vaccinated i'm happy because i was
giving the astrazeneca which is the one
i wanted
with an average of more than 400 deaths
a day and total infections approaching 5
million
most argentines are happy they're
receiving safe effective vaccines
not concerned about where they're coming
from
daniel schreimer al jazeera buenos aires